[Musique]
du haut de cette tour sept siècles
d'histoire vous contemplent installé sur
les hauteurs de munster le château de à
schwarzenburg avait pour mission de
surveiller la puissante abbaye qu
contrebas des moins des luttes de
pouvoir de l'époque médiévale la
forteresse est en ruines depuis le 16e
siècle
aujourd'hui seuls quelques légendes
l'habite encore mais il demeure un
important témoignage du passé
ce château est tout à fait remarquable
d'abord c'est une puissante forteresse
est une des grandes forteresses qui a
été construite au xiiie siècle et qui
est un modèle de défense militaire à ce
moment là avec quelques autres châteaux
qui existent en alsace et donc il a été
construit pour pouvoir surveiller
l'abbaye qui se trouve là en bas et
parce que c'était une abbaye importante
à l'époque et ce château ensuite a connu
toutes sortes de péripéties
je n'entrerai pas dans les détails parce
que ce serait trop long il a été vendu
plusieurs fois il a été restauré uni a
été édifié une très jolie chapelle d'eau
qui reste très vaguement quelques traces
s'il ya encore une quarantaine d'années
en ruine au xviiie siècle il devient un
lieu de balade prisé des romantiques
retrouve une fonction guerrière lors de
la première guerre mondiale
aujourd'hui seuls quelques promeneurs et
une légendaire dame blanche le visite
encore pourtant bien car une large part
zenbook demeure ancré dans le coeur des
habitants de la vallée
ce château est fortement ruinés mais il
est quand même une empreinte de
l'histoire dans la vallée surtout il
fait partie du patrimoine historique
architectural et surtout culturel de la
vallée et c'est pour cela qu'il est
important de le maintenir en état de le
consolider et de le val d'oise est
aujourd'hui quatre nouveaux gardiens
prennent leurs quartiers à la
schwarzenbourg ce sont les veilleurs de
château du conseil départemental
la mission de ces bénévoles surveiller
régulièrement l'évolution de la vieille
forteresse et défricher le terrain pour
éviter que la végétation ne finissent
pas
engloutir le castrale c'est quand même
quelque chose de mon enfance j'habitais
donc à colmar et autour de colmar ya
plein de château et c'était le terrain
de jeu de tous ces châteaux donc le
premier château où j'étais d'ailleurs et
c'était le choc en fait
puis ensuite le schwarzenburg alors
pourquoi ben c'est surtout que je veux
que ça se préserve pour les pour
la génération future quoi j'étais
d'abord sur un autre château qui était
château de kaysersberg et ensuite je
suis mieux et rejoindre mon équipe ici
présentes au château de schwarzenburg
alors issu d'une formation d'histoire de
l'art ça fait depuis que je suis toute
petite que je pratique le pas le
patrimoine et que j'essaye avant tout de
valoriser et de revaloriser notre
patrimoine alsacien
si les parcours sont différents tous ont
en commun une passion pour la sauvegarde
du patrimoine
ce sont des bénévoles avant tout qu'ils
observent et qui rendent compte de
l'évolution des châteaux des châteaux
forts médiévaux qui dans le haut-rhin se
trouve en moyenne montagne et ils
rendent compte de leurs observations au
département qui anime le réseau de ces
veilleurs mais également aux
propriétaires de chacun de ces châteaux
alors ce sont des bénévoles donc des
personnes dont il faut saluer
l'investissement qui vient en plus de
leur vie professionnelle
en plus de leur vie familiale et ils
viennent régulièrement pour la plupart
sur les ruines qui leur ont été
attribués alors qu'on nous avons choisi
ensemble derrière la mission des
veilleurs l'enjeu de la préservation du
patrimoine castrale haut rhinois si
nombre de places fortes aujourd'hui en
ruine au conseil départemental
on souhaite que ces sites soient
accessibles aux promeneurs en toute
sécurité
les veilleurs interviennent en amont
d'éventuels travaux alors dans un
premier temps on construit les choses à
partir de l'observation puisque c'est
l'évolution de l'état de la ruine qui
nous permet d'orienter les mesures
ultérieures à prendre parce qu'on saura
que sur tel pan de mur il ya une urgence
plus nette que sur un autre pan de mur
qui lui n'évolue pas ensuite le veilleur
n'est pas le seul à intervenir
son action est essentielle mais
il trahit il travaille aussi avec le
propriétaire de la ruine avec des
associations alors très souvent il
s'agit du club vosgien et aussi d'autres
institutions l'amérique est souvent
propriétaires la communauté de communes
et le département et c'est la
conjugaison de l'action de l'ensemble de
ces acteurs qui permet en unissant les
moyens et les énergies d'aboutir à un
résultat concret mais qui est à venir
puisque nous sommes au début de la
démarche
le dispositif prend place dans le cadre
plus large d'une politique ambitieuse
pour les trésors historiques
ainsi le département du haut-rhin lancé
fin 2010 8 son plan patrimoine le
patrimoine on a décidé de s'y intéresser
d'abord parce qu'on a mis en place cette
année avec mes collègues est notre
présidente l'a souhaité le plan
patrimoine 68 le plan patrimoine 68 qui
permet de sauver justement le patrimoine
du territoire c'est-à-dire il ya les
maisons anciennes dedans classés ou non
il y aller les sites remarquables
il y a également les châteaux forts qui
en font partie c'est une enveloppe de 9
millions sur trois ans et nous avons
déjà passé pour plus de 2 millions de
dossiers récemment avec mes collègues
qui ont été validés et des travaux qui
vont donc être mis en route le chauffeur
zones bour un diagnostic architectural
est en cours
départements et communautés de communes
entend à terme consolider le château
c'est très important je m'en réjouis
beaucoup de pas de soutien à la
communauté de communes de la commune de
stosswihr du département du club vosgien
qui a beaucoup oeuvré ici c'est très
important parce qu'ils vont passer
régulièrement ils vont couper ce qui
dépasse comme arbus qui ont tendance à
repousser
ils vont nettoyer ils vont consolider
c'est un travail très important que je
crois que nous avons pris le bon chemin
et je me réjouis de tout ce qui va se
passer par la suite
en tout une quarantaine de sites ont été
identifiés dans le haut rhin pour leurs
cinquante personnes interviennent sur
neuf châteaux afin de renforcer son
dispositif
le département est toujours à la
recherche de weyer bénévoles